salary expectation a very
straightforward and common question
asked during an interview the interview
is going well all of a sudden the
interviewer asks you this question and
you're caught off guard
this could be a tricky question to
answer with no prior preparation and
here we are to help you with that so
today we will be addressing this in our
video
this question is asked only to know
whether your expectation aligns with the
company's budget or not it is quite
difficult for a person to put an actual
figure for their work
this question is generally raised
because the interviewer wants to know
what according to you
will be your worth to the company or how
much are you willing to or trying to
value your work the question here is not
very tough however the interviewee falls
into a dilemma so that they don't sound
either too underpaid or overpaid
to answer the question and how to answer
please stay tuned to the full video
don't forget to subscribe to our youtube
channel and click on the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
before answering the question we need to
understand its importance and the reason
it is asked there are three primary
reasons for this
first is the company's budget
as soon as there is a vacancy the salary
range is decided
the compensation you are going to ask
for should ideally fall into that range
second is to know your self-worth
every candidate must know their worth by
checking their skill achievements and
most importantly experience
to do so they can research it by asking
their peers or checking the market value
of the same profile
third is to check whether you are
suitable for the role
you should check your own eligibility
and qualifications
if you are asking a more significant
deal from the company than other
candidates then you ought to be
overqualified for the job or too
experienced
or else requesting a too low salary will
give the impression that you are under
qualified for the job now let's see how
we should answer the salary expectation
question and also certain tips and
tricks to be taken care of firstly
research about the job role to provide
an accurate compensation for the
position you must check on the same
market value to align with the market
average
you can also take help from your peers
working at the same level or who share
the same education level experience poor
achievements
secondly consider the fact that salaries
depend not only on the career or
experience but also on the location the
pay for a rural area will never suffice
in an urban area
various factors like seniority
educational qualification skill sets and
sometimes relocation too are also
considered as important criteria on
which salary should be paid
thirdly try to answer the expectation in
range rather than giving an exact set of
figures for example 1350k
1400k per annum or 1000k to 1050k per
annum don't keep the range very wide a
maximum of 50k will do fourthly the
other compensation and benefits should
be excluded from the range described
it would help if you discussed your
health benefits over time and allowed
leads and equity in the company
to make the interview more interactive
you could ask the interviewer about the
budget that they have already set up
finally averting or avoiding the
question will help you too
however this is the question that you
have to discuss but you could deflect it
until you are well prepared
you can ask for more information about
the job and get acquainted with the
position and working environment and
most importantly you shouldn't ask this
question first rather wait for the
interviewer to bring it up
on that note how will you justify your
salary for the job you are looking for
answer the question in the comment box
below and the best answer will get a
chance to win an amazon voucher there
are specific tips that you must remember
while answering this question
first of all being ambitious is good so
aim high likewise if you want your pay
to be 400k per year
however do not demand 350k to 450k
instead ask for 400k to 450k next as we
all know confidence is the path to
success
if you sound confident while negotiating
the interviewer will see that you are
self-assured and know your worth already
finally justifying your salary can be
done by highlighting your achievements
experience and educational
qualifications if you are expecting more
than the neighborhood average
also do remember there are certain
don'ts for the response too
for example salary expected must not be
responded to in exact figures otherwise
it will portray your unavailability to
open negotiations
aiming too high then the industrial
average will again prevent you from
getting the job
similarly aiming too low will reduce
your opportunities and make the
interviewer think less of you as you
aren't able to sell yourself
willing to work at low compensation is
never appreciated
here are some examples on how you should
answer the question on salary
expectations
you could say
my expectation is around 800k to 850k
per annum as it will be a fair
compensation for my experience and
skills however negotiation can be done
relying on other forms of benefits
offered by the company
you could also say well thanks for
asking for my opinion i feel that an
annual salary between 700 to 750k
is in line with the local average my
expertise skill set will suffice this
range
with this we've come to the end of the
video so these were the tips to help you
frame your answer better remember the
do's and don'ts and do a self-analysis
before you answer the salary question in
an interview
i hope you found this video helpful stay
tuned to our channel simply learn to
watch more informative and interesting
videos best of luck
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here